a month after putin's criminal invasion
the strength of our unity
has turned russia into an
international pariah with serious damage to its
economy but if we want to resist and
support the admirable
ukrainian resistance we must direct all
our efforts on two fronts
keep up the pressure on  putin and
strengthen the strategic autonomy of
the european union in energy and
defense sanctions have lived up to
this moment but we must and can
do much more cut off
russia's access to cryptocurrency exchanges
persecute the tax havens they
protect  sanctioned health coffers
further isolate russian energy banks and
giants and end our
dependence on gas and oil from the
kremlin the weakness of our
energy system was always a known truth
that the russian war has laid
bare today  we must face the challenges
we have to free ourselves from energy dependence
on russia
speed up t  As far as possible, the
energy transition and managing
Russian gas prices must be supplemented by diversifying
gas energy sources and
increasing interconnections. The
creation of strategic reserves and
joint purchasing would also increase
our energy resilience and if
we really want to make
our strategic autonomy a reality.  and to lead
a global transition we must accelerate
the rate of installation of renewables
let's be honest defense is the
price of freedom and democracy
are causing the price
of fuels for fertilizers
for cereals to rise and this pushes us to make
urgent decisions  taxation must
continue to be an
essential tool to face the cost of
the crisis the design of a mechanism that
lowers the most vulnerable families and companies
and at the same time that we
increase taxes on electricity companies
for the benefits that fell from the sky would
allow us to balance the  costs
of the crisis it is also
essential to totally reform the
marginalist system that governs the price
of the electricity market in the union it is
time to decouple the price of
electricity from the price of gas we
cannot continue to look the other way and
we know that the price of gas  causes
uncontrolled rises in prices
despite accounting for a very
small fraction of total electricity generation
putin's cowardly attack
also makes it inevitable that we increase
our spending on defense but it's not just
about spending more it's about spending
better and therefore  both the
strategic compass designed by mr borrel
gives us the opportunity to use
our capacities efficiently
in these tragic hours almost 4
million men, women and children have knocked
on the doors of the european union
the adoption of a
package of  protection that cover the
basic needs of children and
are the future of an admirable  people
who are now fighting for their freedoms and
also for ours, the mobilization
and gestures of solidarity with the
refugees must not only be maintained
while the war lasts, but must
lead us to a new
migration and asylum pact that can no
longer wait for the  images of the
monstrous attacks against the
civilian population are testimony to the
war crimes committed by putin the
international criminal court cannot leave
the barbarism of this man of
putin unpunished the european union must also
fulfill the sacrifices that each state
can assume for an action  joint venture of
the european union will allow
civic and democratic consciousness to
prevail thank you very much so cream